yes
this is the committee on commissions
and this is September 11th
2023 let me say we're not going to say
the Pledge of Allegiance we don't have
that as our custom on this committee but
I I would like to take a moment of
silence to remember the sacrifices uh on
that come on the sacrifices on 9 11 and
that we all think back that was
a long time ago but let's never forget
so let's just take a moment to remember
all those who died especially the folks
in New York and the Pentagon and
Pennsylvania
today we're going to uh
dive back into this project well welcome
back everybody our last meeting was in
June
here we are in September uh kicking
this there should you should all have an
agenda in front of you
we're going to go through through the
agenda and then uh
I'll tell you that John and I met with
the speaker
huh
several weeks ago in late
in late June
and I'll debriefs with you about the
speaker's comments
and where we are and also have some some
things some goals we'd like to achieve
during this
uh next few months
today is uh is Legend week so this is
the week that if you want to put in
legislation
and we're certainly not ready in this
committee to Output legislation yet so
it won't really affect us but there's a
lot of people scurrying around getting
their legislative comments into
uh
into the folks downstairs uh across the
uh across the road so
we need to respect that activity that
it's only going to last a week
so
but I I have I do have some news for you
in that regard and how it will apply to
this committee but we'll go over that in
a little while uh after we've heard from
our special guests so Deb if you'd like
to take it from here for the next next
few that's
good that's a thank you so much Mr
chairman all committee members
thank you for allowing us time again to
come back and share some of the updates
that we've accomplished over the summer
and we have some more information to
provide to you and help you do
um make your decisions and do your job
more effectively hopefully
agenda we're going to review uh just
give a high level review of our meeting
from May 22nd and then dive into some of
our Improvement opportunities the master
list that we've talked about continuing
education proposals the tri-fold that
we've we've talked about having
available through OLS and then
committees that could potentially be
reviewed to to repeal
so starting out with a review of the May
22nd meeting and so um I'm Ann
Fitzgerald director of house community
services and as you know we're Staffing
your um special committee and uh back on
May 22nd you charged staff with five
things to do and Deborah just listed
them and that's why we that was
basically the
um
what we decided uh to move forward you
needed us to track down this information
for you which we have done if we don't
have the information
completed we definitely have an update
on what we have been working on
throughout the summer so that's what we
so the the master list the master list
was the list of statutory and study
committees that you guys are are looking
for
um we have we went back and forth on
this because we all right now staff the
different departments have their own
spreadsheet because we have different
fields where we need different
information my role and I'm sorry I
didn't introduce myself Deborah child's
Deputy Chief of Staff and the only
reason I don't have my name tag on is
because my desk is all packed up there's
some furniture movement going on
um but so I have my master list house
committee Services has one the Senate
has one and what we're really trying to
do is get to one list that everybody can
access so we working with it now have an
export function from these statutory and
study committee page up on the screen
here this is the statutory and study
committee search page is everybody
familiar with this
let's see
oh is that hard to say it's where you
can go in and search for a committee
using the RSA or the name or a text
search so today a lot of folks use this
to find information who's appointed to
what committee what committees exist we
are still working to clean up the data
however an easier way for us to do this
and give folks the function to be able
to pull all of the data out of the
system is we've created this new section
here export committee details
and if you can't see it sorry I'll send
a link out after the meeting too just to
make sure everybody has access to the
page and you can find this export
function
so it's export committee details and for
right now you can search active
statutory committees
and active study committees you could do
one or the other there is the
possibility of doing archived as well
however because the we're only focusing
on cleanup of the data of active
committees we don't have the archived in
the search if that's something that you
would require that you think would be
helpful there's about 1500 I believe
archived statutory and study committees
if you want that information all
upstairs yes exactly but for now so if
we want to export this data it exports
into like a spreadsheet it's called a
CSV but I'm going to export all active
statutory committees and active study
and then it exports and I'm sorry we're
having technical problems before so no I
can't
um
there we go sorry this is not my laptop
because we were having technical
problems but it exports into this export
CSV and if you open it up
it provides all of the active statutory
and study committees and commissions
boards
all of them
yeah
yes thank you and you can see all the
columns at once I'm just doing this
demonstration so you see how simple it
is I'll send you the link you can find
the export it's basically just pushing
the button and it opens it up in Excel
now the reason you'll see multiple lines
for every single commission is because
this is pulling out all the appointments
so administrative rules for example has
multiple Senate and and speaker
appointments so there's a line item for
every appointee
we this is our second iteration of this
export function so we're hoping to have
more not hoping we will have more Fields
eventually which you know as we work on
cleaning out this data we'll have more
Fields available to you but we have some
of the key Fields exported now which
will have the you know the committee or
commission name uh effective date if
there's a repeal date and it will have a
list of the appointees the RSA number
and information like that so our goal is
we're not talking about and spreadsheet
or Deborah's spreadsheet and picking
that apart we have one export and if
there are issues which there are some
data issues we get that fixed in the
system this is a huge first step for us
from a staff perspective because we're
looking at all kinds of potential
improvements and ways we can use it to
thank you thank you that's great
um
history and you have to go down to the
bottom representative go all the way
down to the bottom and you see in the
black ribbon down we'd like to move it
up but you have to go all the way down
to the bottom ribbon and it'll say
statutory and steady
um
committees
and and then that that will lead you to
it
thank you
and now as I mentioned uh
you know this is going to be huge for us
to help validate and clean up the data
so please don't get frustrated if you if
you look at a committee and you see
somebody who isn't even a House member
anymore for example and they're listed
in here this is a great opportunity we
haven't had this before we now have this
we're working to automate a lot of
manual processes so so please be patient
if you have any questions at all you can
always reach out to me reach out to Ann
and her team and I've got a question for
you is is this more than single use what
I mean that is can multiple people
access the state at the same time
absolutely and one of the great things
so you could take this export the data
and then you have your own
spreadsheet that you could potentially
work from however once we update the
data it's live so if you run a you could
run an export now and then you could run
an export in 20 minutes and there could
be something different yeah my concern
was it doesn't lock anybody out so if
I'm in there looking around doesn't lock
John out no it's all real time okay okay
and then at the bottom of the export
um something we had asked it to put at
the bottom was the total number so if
you scroll to the bottom of the the
export you'll see the total number of
statutory commissions which I believe
was 156 when I last did the export and
then study committees and that was in
the 20s or 30s
yeah can you do from the top can you do
keyword circuits on certain you know to
see if it pulls up this committee is
like this committee is like this
committee so this is where our
duplication can
you can on on this search page you can
search on text text is often very
helpful you know I I often use the RSA
or the committee name but the keyword
you could type marijuana for example to
see if there are multiple marijuana
commissions yeah cool okay now uh them
one of the things that we're going to
try to do this fall is
is sort the data
by chairman
so is that case is this system capable
now to say show me all the Committees
that tier into the Edna committee chair
or whatever
so unfortunately not yet that's a field
we keep in our spreadsheet so that's one
of the issues we haven't been able to
break from our spreadsheets and use this
technology but now we have this export
we're looking to add Fields so we don't
have to keep our separate spreadsheets
that is information I can provide to you
a list of the chairman in the list of
how we have it broken down just so
you're aware when a committee is created
or a commission is created there'll be
an original jurisdiction you know maybe
it was a children and family that
created the commission but now the
jurisdiction may be Judiciary for
example so there's an original when you
get that data from us it it'll have
original jurisdiction that's when the
legislation was created and then there's
now the the now jurisdiction the
committee with jurisdiction well what
we're going to start doing uh soon is
calling committee chairs in to this
meeting room
and
talk to them about the oversight they
have about various committees and and
commissions that tear up into their
chairmanship
and it will be helpful to know for
example
Mr or Ms committee chair you have 40
commissions or committees that tear into
your community so we can kind of confine
the argument a little bit when we're
talking to them about about the future
and so that would be a very helpful uh
additional capability to this to this
list yes and I I did anticipate that so
I did give a heads up to our our chairs
that you may be reaching out
right so they should be aware of their
commissions some are more experienced
than others or aware of their
commissions some of them serve on almost
all of their commissions so
and
so we are still working with it again
like I said the the top priority for us
now is working to clean up that data and
then we have some other improvements
we're working on probably a little early
to share with you
um some of the automation plans but but
we should be able to share that in the
next couple of weeks just for for your
information because every Improvement we
can make as staff not only helps our
lives and improves our processes but it
helps the legislators as well
yeah
I think that covers everything for
master list okay so I'll take on um the
house continuing ed program
um that we're going to have on studies
so if you all have a draft in front of
you uh of a proposal that we it's based
on programs we've done in the past and I
have to share with you having done at
least three of these in the last 15
years or so they are one of the best
attended programs that we have we
usually do 2 10 to 11 and you can't get
into the room so many people come in
just for this
um and as you can see we it's
I was going to use names that we used to
you
um of participants that I thought I
would just make it more General to say
staff panel member panel and we cover we
have handouts on every single item we
have descriptions and definitions and we
go into great depth explaining to the
membership what all the different types
of committees are and then obviously we
we also emphasize the study committees
and commissions
um and you can see it would you know
obviously an intro and welcome by a
facilitator or possibly speaker
and then we describe the different
vehicles for study as we've referred to
them and then go into a description if
if the member chooses to create a study
committee or commission uh sponsor
responsibilities
um standing committee process and the
first named obligations like for
instance right now I have a House member
who's been after me for four straight
days because he is first named to a
Senate bill but see we have to do all
this background work trying to figure
out the Senate bill and
um this is one of the items that we're
talking about but I have to educate this
member on why it's taking so long
um because I can't understand why can't
I just call a meeting so um anyway that
is part of what we would like to explain
and then a Roundtable discussion that
can be the value of what a study is
um and how that can help the membership
and help the process but then examining
do do should we have prospective repeal
dates so it could be um
a wonderful opportunity for current
members I mean some freshmen to give
some perspective but we will
um as we go through this process and we
get suggestions from the committee on
how um we think it would it would work
best
um then we can just move forward and the
um I think the membership will really
like this program
um and you can see a staff panel would
be similar to our presentation or what
we did for you back in April
and um there may it will be live
streamed and on YouTube and there may be
an afternoon program that has nothing to
do with studies there may be this is
what we've done in the past we've
dedicated a full day to house continuing
ed and the speaker may choose okay let's
have this subject in the morning the
subject in the afternoon
um we proposed I think I did Wednesday
but I think October 12th is a Thursday
um we're suggested Thursday October 12th
is a possibility because we were hoping
that most retained commies would already
get going by then and that might be a a
good time where the membership could
come in and um
and participate in this program
so this is just
um a proposal that we want to bring
before the committee as you asked us to
create a continuing ed
option and we developed this as I
mentioned based on previous programs
so that's it and we have all the
material that we need I was going to
copy it all but I just thought there was
more there would just be more
information
yes absolutely
yeah speaking of mileage the systems
back up
of those of you who were
denied the ability to put in mileage
over the summer you're you're in
September right you can The Summer's
over according to our our calendar so uh
you can you can go to the kiosk and put
okay so that is the date we're planning
on we ran that past the speaker in
leadership if you have any concerns with
thank you
so we have the trifold
all right I'll start with uh so the OLS
tri-fold pamphlet and
I'll first talk about why we decided to
do the tri-fold pamphlet
this is basically some so we can educate
folks on the on the process of statutory
and study committees explain the
difference of the two and provide some
tips some some questions to ask before
filing a bill to create a new committee
or commission and then some suggestions
of uh content
this this will be in line with our
continue continuing ed program you know
it'll be like supplemental material but
it will be a trifold that will include
in ORS as well
similar along the lines of creating this
tri-fold we're also looking at
boilerplate language for these
committees and commissions just to make
sure they're standardized we've had a
lot of problems in the past for example
not having a Sunset date having
commission names that take up the full
screen when you come in in the morning
because they're so long instead of
limiting the characters
just some having consistency like the
the first named host member will kick
off or schedule the organizational
meeting for a house bill but the first
name Senate member would do that for a
Senate bill
we are still working on this we have a
draft of the trifold but not yet ready
to share with you today because it's all
departments we're working to make sure
all of our pieces are clear and concise
and can fit in the tri-fold but we
should have that available for your
review either end of this week or next
and just so you're aware the the speaker
plans to meet with the Senate President
to after we get through all of this
initial work just to try to see if we
can stay on the same page as at least as
much as possible the house and the
Senate so we have consistency
and then I'll turn it over to you and as
Sarah mentioned with the trifold our
goal is um to list what each office does
or is responsible for but as concise as
possible because after a while people
can't hear what you're sharing but it's
good for them to know what this is all
about and give them a backstory but in
the meantime there is going to be an
email going out explaining the process
so as we have members gearing up this
week
to who knows if there are commissions
looming out there just to explain
consider this because some of the items
that has been brought to our attention
for instance is
um the 45-day
um effective date where did that come
from why do we have that and and you you
remember saying well that's what they
gave me but I prefer this okay but that
that that's a conversation that goes on
between the drafter and the sponsor
nobody else participates but sometimes
the sponsor doesn't know what questions
to ask and the drafters assuming via an
email that this is what the sponsor
wants
um and that is problem that we just
shared with that Senate bill that I
mentioned where the house Members First
named a senator cut and paste and sent
it to a less and they said oh this is
what the senator wants but that isn't
at the time that wasn't their goal so
anyway there are little things like that
and
um we just want to get people to think
all right so if I'm putting in a study
what is it that I want to do what do I
want to study as we've talked about
before and I won't go over everything
we've shared last spring
but we're hoping that this trifold
that's the goal to get it to the members
and so they can refer to that and at
least provoke some or make them think
about what their end goal is for
whatever study they're creating
and um as Deborah mentioned we had hoped
we we had hoped we had more some
something more solid for you today but
because of all the different offices
being involved and and just tweets why
give you the best product that we can
give you and we figured a few more days
um would be better than it than a you
know basic draft Yeah and yeah and we're
open to releasing it in a draft form we
just want to you know make sure it's as
clear as possible and has a helpful
content but then releasing it as a draft
and getting feedback from those who are
utilizing it would be helpful and we can
make improvements before we we finalize
it
but this is an important part that we we
can't emphasize enough the importance of
you know and and where we may need your
help as far as a boilerplate and it may
not just be continuing ed and creating a
trifle but possibly including rules
changing our house rules or putting
something in statute to help
um
just to help get this consistency I
think a lot of people don't understand
how much churn can be caused when when
things are not consistent we did have uh
one recently the the charitable gaming
commission was created and there were
several problems with that that created
so much work for staff and legislators
up to the Senate President and the
speaker and just as one example in that
um
commission there were some appointees
that didn't say who the appointing
authority is so for example generally it
will say the speaker of the house will
appoint two members the Senate President
will appoint one member well there were
some others listed and it didn't say who
the authority was of course we had to
have meetings talk about that what are
we going to do somebody assumed that the
house Clerk or the Senate clerk would
make appointments they don't make
appointments so what we did was have the
Senate President make one of the
appointments and the Speaker of the
House made one of the appointments as
well working with the with the leaders
but it creates a lot of churn
with how some of these are created and
if it's not standard and in this
particular case it started way back in
the spring when it when it was initially
in there and that took some work by the
committee and then that
the
um people who were representing it was
just so it led to a lot of confusion at
the time but it did pass and it was
vetoed and it was inserted in House Bill
2 so now it's no longer it was Senate
Bill initially now it's a house bill and
we have to figure it out and as Deborah
mentioned it's not just a few people
sitting around there were multiple
meetings on multiple phone calls of
legal counsel house clerks Senate Clerk
and and so that takes a good deal of
time and in days and so that's the type
of thing that we're trying to avoid and
we could have avoided all of this by
upon drafting if the sponsor said this
this is where I'd like it's my
appointing authority and that piece will
also be in the trifold that you have to
think that through I think I may have
mentioned in our previous meeting set
years ago
um we used to literally there wouldn't
be appointing authorities and so say
you're a 21-member commission and would
just list a teacher from New Hampshire
so staff would get together and we'd all
between the clerk's office our office
and we get phone books out and we'd
start looking and and trying to find
names and people
um and match them up and calling
different associations
um so this this is way better than it
was but it's still challenging and
that's why we know when there's no
appointing authority it can cause
problems
well it's nice to hear that you weren't
calling individual teachers just trying
to solicit their interests whether it's
actually associations
um I think it's the you know it's
efficiency and effectiveness of of
everyone who works here that we need to
be looking out for and so uh I think
this makes a ton of sense and I think we
should be creative right outside of the
continuing education outside of an email
to the Eunice membership
um let's make sure that we're continuing
to reiterate how important this is also
smart not to roll all this out right
before osr filing otherwise we might
have seen double the number of study
committees and commissions that I think
we're I think we're on the right track
and thanks thanks for the work that you
put into thank you to getting this
together because it's not about it's not
about oh well it stinks that you know
they
y'all are you know
you know the president need to get
together and work on this it's not
that's not the issue it's the issues
you've got other things on your plate uh
and we need to make sure that everyone's
spending their time in the smartest way
possible
right one of the things we had mentioned
last spring was that we're going to work
with elaconis and his crew about putting
together a legislative template
is that integrated with a trifold is
that is that where the trifold takes us
that it has evolved somewhat into the
tri-fold and we still are working on the
template but there's they they have to
look at their own system see how it can
work so it may
I think it might um possibly we can come
up with a plan for maybe the following
um filing term but it won't be ready for
this for this week but the trifold it
seems to me that that would be readily
fixable if we put it in the template
that
you have to have this you have to
um look for a sponsor or whatever or you
know uh that that's part of the things
to check off on the template that you
know have you done this and if you
haven't then
we'll get let's see if we can get OLS to
kick it back so you haven't followed the
template
well representative I think it's one of
the options you're absolutely right that
that that's but I think we're looking at
all those options and what best could
work with the OLS system
so um so I mean it's still on on the
table so uh I I don't mean to get get
ahead of your briefing but will we uh be
able to hear from OLS soon about how
they're work how they're doing with that
template that we asked for
so so the initial plan is to get this
the tri-fold out there because that will
have a checklist of you know some of the
concerns we've had in the past and what
could be included in it then I think the
template would be the next step that the
template is where we really need your
help as legislators because even OLS
it's hard to to push back when a
legislator wants to submit legislation
they can only push back so much so
having this tri-fold approved by
legislators will be have you looked into
these things first and here are some
things you should include in your in
your do do you think we need to have a
working session with OLS to mature the
template
entered this week so so this week or
next we'll have the tri-fold ready for
you and we'd like to roll that out as a
draft as soon as possible for all
legislators and then I think that you
know seeing how that goes and what may
change in in that will help drive out
the the template but then the template I
think we it would be a collaborative
effort it's you know I think OLS is
challenged with they could create a
template but if a legislator chooses not
to use it then there's not much
obviously we won't have the template
ready for the legislative or work to be
done this week right so yeah and and
one one thing I want to mention too is
remember that the majority of the
commissions and committees come later in
the year though some are initially
requested during this filing period
it'll be a few compared to the number
that come later you know lots of times
you're looking at a bill and it's not
necessarily
um
maybe it needs more work so it turns
into a study committee or which is fine
or a statutory commission so you know if
we can get that tri-fold up and running
it in good shape and you know get
feedback and input into that maybe we
can look to get the template so what do
you need from us for the trifold just to
review it yes certainly yeah certainly
and when you guys give kind of a stamp
of approval on the draft we could we
could share it with the rest of the
legislators and then you know test it
out and you have a feel when it will be
ready for us to review either this week
right it might it might be I would think
next only because we want all of us to
participate and this isn't a good week
to ask them for participation
we're probably going to meet again in
Yeah man so
you brought up you know statute and
rules is another way to address some of
these the consistency in the the
standards here and I wonder
I think we should just all be thinking
about that because
whether it's this year or it's next year
or in the future
um
you know there's nothing that keeps a
legislator from looking at the tri-fold
brochure and saying well I don't want to
do it that way
and but if we put something into rules
or into statute then it would then it
would require everyone to use that
template so get an administrative rules
they have to follow it yeah I mean or
put into house yeah we're proposing that
um for you we're going to Paul is
working on he wants a list of what we
may want for rules and then we'll also
have them for RSA 1449 for and then as
you remember position the the
um vehicle in in Legend that's sitting
there for us
um or for the committee to um
because the student retained Bill's
status that may be amended with this
information so we are looking that we
have a we have a list that we're
maintaining to uh share with you at a
future meeting of possibilities and one
of them as Deborah mentioned the lengthy
titles that just doesn't help anybody
and then
um we have other
items that you may not all be aware of
for instance and we came across this one
um
it if you go to our docket the docket
will say uh that this committee hasn't
met in possibly two or four years they
actually have been meeting every month
but they have an outside entity because
it's 21 members but only two legislators
so they they have a life of their own
and in that uh we we found their web
page and in that it has a little um it
says legislatively approved they have a
little seal that they created that but
they never send the information they
don't reach out to the members once
they're appointed they do not
um send their information to the house
or the Senate Clerk's offices
so for our purposes we believe they're
not meeting and then turns out yes they
certainly are meeting off-site and have
been meeting
um and we stumbled upon that because
someone remembered that there was a
presentation and then we researchers
went online and we found it we said
they've been meeting right along and
but
no
they do follow reports but they don't
have to send them to us or they may or
they may be such a commission that
doesn't have to report there is such a
thing and they just
they they just do yeah what they need to
do I'm actually glad you mentioned that
so you know the export when you export
data from the statutory and study
committee page so if you're looking at
that last meeting held and you see 2008
that may be old data
it may be old data because the house and
the Senate generally update the the back
end where that data is they update it
when somebody tells them to they're not
looking at these 200 commissions and and
keeping it up to date it's somebody will
send them an appointment notice okay
these are the house members and they'll
update or this is when the last meeting
was held and they'll update that so just
keep that in mind if you know because I
could imagine you'd see that column and
say oh let's search to see when they
haven't met that that's not 100 accurate
we are trying to uh
share information with you when we know
that there's a committee that could
potentially be repealed so
we'll take that with a grain of salt
sorry I know Ian wanted to speak to why
don't you go ahead no you go ahead sure
okay I was going to ask is there any
reason why even if a committee is
meeting or a commission is meeting under
an executive department uh with only a
couple legislative appointees or any
reason why they shouldn't be filing
reports with
the House and Senate clerks no only if
it's in the legislation that created
them
that's where it sits
um as I share with you we created that
boilerplate language in 95 to make sure
that the reports were submitted
specifically to Senate President the
speaker the governor and the State
Library
um
but this this one or they may they may
they could possibly submit it and only
submit it to the governor they may not
see the need because stuff get those the
chairmanships of these groups changes
over and then something they just
appoint people they don't even realize
they didn't even think about
the originating legislation that created
them so they may just say well this is
how our group functions now and
and then you have new membership that
they just reappoint and it never comes
back here okay so that is something that
we could consider down the line as you
know standardizing the way the reporting
process works yeah to make sure that all
reports for all committees and
commissions are filed with the Senate
President because that's what we did in
95 as I mentioned so that language sits
there but there are still some groups
who won't do it got it okay and that's
and that's what we try but this is what
we're finding out and that's what we're
saying it's taking such a long time that
we're coming we're coming upon these
items as we're searching
and so many of these they're volunteer
driven right I mean it's so it's people
are just sort of taking
first of all it probably took them a lot
like with State reps who you sometimes
beg to run for office takes takes a lot
to get them to say yes and then once
they say yes they're getting
certain amount of information from
certain people not necessarily reviewing
the statute that that created their
entity to begin with
so I was I was thinking uh along the
line with Matt
put that little tick mark on the
checklist
you know because this is you know this
is why we're reviewing this check
checklist for things exactly like this I
bet it's on there in your binder
um there's there's a section that gives
the history of how we um came up with
the different the different years when
we created boilerplate language but we
can it's all just in a narrative we
could pull it out and create a chart
just to add
different different commissions may have
different reporting requirements though
often times they have they're due around
the same time November 1st December 1st
whatever that may be there's nothing
holding these people accountable to make
sure they do their reports even if it's
in statute
and then also the reports since they're
all due around the same time the Senate
President speaker Governor is receiving
these reports all at once and so if
they're not you know
getting anything else saying hey I'd
like to meet with you to review the
report it's just a stack of reports and
of course they can't review all of these
reports at one time so that that I do
find is another issue hopefully that
different commissions are taking them
and and running with them and doing what
they need to do but it's rare from my
perspective working with the speaker
it's rare when somebody says oh I'd like
some time with the speaker to review
this report
we put so much time and effort into
these commissions and committees that
and some of these reports look beautiful
there's a lot of data they've put in so
much work so I just would like to know
what's happening after with some of them
and we and as um Deborah mentioned
we we don't know if the reports come in
in some cases we obviously will get them
to the um standing committee chairs but
we file them and some people will just
the commission may never have met
um if you
they couldn't get a quorum and so they
never met and their their family report
will just be a letter to the speakers
and president and Governor saying that
we could never make a quorum so this is
our report
just this letter and it's unfortunate
but
um that's part of this process
um that's why as we've mentioned before
we put a lot of energy into
supporting Administration disappointing
these commissions administratively at
least at the front end and whereas if
it's a chaptered study or even the
commission you can stay you can study
that issue but you don't have the the
um dedicate staff time to create to
track down the people or to get it all
set up or find a meeting place or
whatever it may take to make that happen
and then you if you don't make quarma we
have had lots of members
stuck in that waiting and you're waiting
for different groups to appoint and if
they don't appoint you you can't
so it's just one more roadblock let me
ask you a rules question if
if a
committee fails to meet Forum
consistently
and that is is uh appears to be
justification to eliminate that
committee because it never meets quorum
is that something that has to be
accomplished with legislation to
eliminate that committee or can there be
a rule that says if Quorum is not met
you know in six consecutive tries that
the committee is decommissioned well I
would double check with Paul with the
clerk and house counsel but I I would
think that it would have to be
legislation because it's law that
created the commission
and it's law I think you'd have to have
a repeal date but in many of these
instances
um
they do are automatically have a
reporting deadline or appeal date and
that's what's unfortunate is that they
get to that deadline and you haven't
been able to meet
because they didn't have one and then
it's automatically repealed or yes or
ended when it hits that date exactly you
don't need legislation for that yeah
because it's already built into
legislation it's part of the boilerplate
language okay for the for our
committee's edification
when speaking with a speaker uh in June
uh one of the things that he's going to
allow us to do is recognize that our
legislative window closes
this week
so the question is what do we do about
legislation that might need to be filed
to eliminate some of these committees
uh these commissions and the the thought
is that he shared with uh what John and
I was that
you come to the rules committee
and you ask for a special legislative
window to be opened to allow some of
this activity to take place and uh
in their in the kindness of their hearts
they're likely to approve that the rules
can be so that that would be the plan of
attack we don't need to say at the end
of this week
we don't have the legislator ready to go
legislation ready to go
you know we're done until next spring no
there isn't another available
opportunity with this with the speakers
uh
cooperation
to sponsor through the through the rules
committee
and I think there's some special window
in your committee doing allegi admin too
that I'm not sure I completely
understand
to retained a bill so we have you know
through October to
work on that as well okay and and they
can move forward Anthony
yeah and they can move it forward and by
and before we move to the last item I
just wanted to you would ask the
question about reaching a quorum and I
know that's extremely frustrating we've
had a couple
um recently too where the the chair will
put in a lot of effort to schedule the
meeting they'll work in advance for to
make sure they have a quorum and then a
quorum doesn't show up but in my
experience working with the speaker if
it happens multiple times it's generally
somebody from the commission will reach
out to me and say hey your house member
isn't showing up we need a new appointee
so that's another option as well you
know you know maybe that house member
didn't have interest in the commission
maybe they don't have time anymore but
we can get another appointee out to try
to make sure a quorum is reached
administratively I think our video timed
out do you need to do anything to
this no this was just for the uh the
quick little demo of the export yeah
thank you
and so the the last uh section here we
want to talk about is go over committees
that could potentially be reviewed for
it's hot it is it is warm in here
um this is
we added to this list we gave you five
back in um in May
um and then we've been obviously you've
seen the updates down in the far right
hand corner and we've added a few more
so we're up to nine and
um Deborah thinks we're gonna have a few
more maybe another two or three but we
looked through
um these were the unique
um
commissions that
um we know that you want to see uh
what was out there that hadn't been
meeting that needed to meet and so we
did was we took the leftover list from
representative Evil's committee and
updated that and then we went through
other items that we were aware of and
you'll see see us committee's citation
the year was created
the appointees the government agency and
then the notes as to why
um
they may not have met or that they may
have met
um and it explains
um
why these items are still in existence
so these this list May Encompass
um members that you want to ask uh to
come in before you and ask them what
their plans are because this is
um what you had been reviewing
we were hoping the list would be a
little bit longer but this is at least a
starting point as we get more we'll
share them with you we also met with the
Senate this morning and asked if they
could do a similar activity if there are
any that they're aware that could
potentially be repealed or looked at at
least and then just also keep in mind we
have study committees that will be
self-repealing this year and next year
too so there are some numbers that you
don't need to file legislation on that
will repeal
yeah I mean I was just thinking of the
numbers if let's say we have a couple of
dozen committee chairs if we say bring
us one
from your committee
so uh I think we think it's doable to
start getting some momentum on this and
I I can tell you
uh having
firsthand observation of some of the
Committees of conference that we went
through in June
I know that uh
one of the ones on Edna the Senate
wanted to
create
a you know a commission and all the
members of the House part of the
committee conference Democrats and
Republicans said no way we got enough no
more in that Community Conference died
and they would the committee was not
created so that's
I don't claim that as a victory but it's
it's one less than we would have had if
it had been
agreed to create another
so so that I take that as a small
snippet of information that committee
chairs are getting the word that we have
too many
too many committees and too many
commissions and they're ready to
you know turn the speaker off so to
speak and that was a good example of
that so
maybe we can build on that
I'll get into this in a little while as
we brief the speaker uh and we were
John and I were kind of claiming victory
that we were getting the right frame of
mind and the template and the trifold
was all coming together and one of the
things that somebody in speaker staff
said I forget who it was and
that's that's good but do you realize
we've had
two dozen more commissions created since
since you guys started up so we'll
the feedback was kind of we're losing
ground uh and we need to be probably a
little bit more aggressive going forward
and I agree with you that education and
awareness will will you know helping to
spread the word will get people thinking
of other ways to do this and when we do
the the tri-fold and the continuing add
to reminding folks that you don't have
to create a statutory commission to to
meet on a subject you know study
committees are great but you can also
pop and any chair can create a
subcommittee you can you can meet on
these things without creating
legislation for them and and that's the
subcommittee route can take a lot of the
starch out of this uh this is this is
issue
um and then we also have the chaptered
studies which are members only but we
have told a lot of our members which is
what we used to it we have shared with
you commissions used to be rare what we
did was we had the chaptered studies of
house senate members and then you'd
invite you you literally could invite
the people to sit at the table and talk
but then
um it just evolved to create the
commissions and then they wanted these
other entities to be voting members and
that's how it came about
and and
this really wouldn't apply in front
another year or so but when we brief
it goes through orientation for new uh
new house members I think one of the
issues
that
new house members deal with is they they
come they're all excited about their
campaign and they they have a victory
and then they they say I'm gonna go and
save world hunger and they they show up
and they they have members of the public
who elicited
commitments from them say I'm going to
go do such and such for you and what
that does in many cases is filing
a request for a committee to study it
well we know I don't know really what to
do with this issue but we'll study it
for a few years
and that's I think what gets us into
trouble in many cases is we don't really
know about all these commitments to go
study something that we're really dead
in some cases doesn't really have the
the interest that much of the of that
new representative but the
representative has made a commitment to
a constituent that they're going to go
study something and and then
the rest of us are left with how to
staff that and is it really worth
studying and
so that's something I think we can help
educate
our new house members to be very careful
about making commitments the
constituency you're going to go study
a majority of of house members that
really want to go do that and and this
is to just satisfy a constituent by
doing this
you might really be driving the cost of
government and
and driving you know all of us to go do
things that may not be necessary and
rips and Dolan that that's you're
exactly right in that that's part of the
piece with the trifold we have a series
of questions we're hoping that we might
incorporate that we developed as well
and it's those questions
um and we've shared with you before have
you done research did you check with OLS
research is it was a study before and
just make sure that that sponsor checks
off all those lists and say oh well I
didn't realize that a commission already
exists on this or that the agency could
easily help
um resolve a situation
so you're exactly right if we can
obviously we're looking at
um attack news from all ends from
continuing ed from the tri-fold from
staff and
you know I I keep thinking this is this
is the last chance to fix this thing and
we're all we're almost there at least
well thank you so much for all this
additional work that you've done over
the summer it's been very helpful you're
welcome I'm really uh looking forward to
that what that trifold looks like and
and
providing feedback
so we can move out with it
anybody else have any comments for staff
right
yeah John well I'm I'm happy
that there will be guidance
because up to now
there really hasn't been any formal
guidance for new members
to do this and I know when I came in you
know you look around and you go what I
don't how do I do this stuff and when
you have even at the at the at the
introduction meetings there was no
guidance on how to do this
and any guidance that we provide will be
get so much payback it's ridiculous
because
I think you will I mean I've had new
members you've had new members come to
you go how do we do this
and you're going
wait a minute I never had training on it
either
well I was the chair of Museum and
County a couple years ago
and yeah I didn't I can tell you I
didn't have a Clues how many committees
or commissions
I should have been overseeing or looking
into or or helping decide what what
their
workload ought to be or what their focus
ought to be and I I would say that I
don't think I I'm an isolated was an
isolated chair I think a lot of Cheers
are in that role and you ask them how
many how many committees or commissions
you fall into tear into you as a
committee chair I think most of them are
going to shrug their shoulders and say I
have no idea and I think educating them
along those lines is a big first step
exactly just giving this visibility we
had some shares who said
appoint me to all of my commissions that
the policy committee has jurisdiction
over just so they can get to know them
and understand is it really needed can
they be Consolidated or repealed so yeah
has been helpful yeah this is a this is
a Quantum Leap
of what from what we had so I think a
lot of members are going to really
appreciate it and then
like we we have some knowledge about it
you know some things winner we may not
even have realized and then we have when
we have new members coming in we can
mentor them
and say here if this is the checklist
that we've can come up with and that
we're using oh it's really nice better
than you know this that we've had in the
past
so I'm all for it and so so what what's
the the opportunity let's look at what
what do we expect
in the next election
of 2024.
what do we think we're going to get for
for rookie legislators
but what's typical the 50 or 60 a third
about a third
so so that that is the opportunity I
think
to uh to really educate them as to how
well one of the items during orientation
they have so much to learn during those
first two and a half days traditionally
years ago we used to have a the
continuing ad component would follow up
right after that and we could
parliamentary procedure and this was one
of the items that we would do but as we
all know
covid changed a lot of our practices and
and we're just um embracing everything
again so relate to this but certainly in
whoever the new leadership would be in
January 2025
this would be something they could look
at because you do it is so much
information and members need to to get
there to understand exactly how this
process runs and then understands
understand what the studies are
right
hope it also gave us the opportunity to
Fast Track technology here though is
true as well as you know so yes we're
trying to take advantage of that too
so hopefully what we've given you is is
helpful
um you know we've got the export so you
have a list of the Committees and
commissions
and continuing ed I believe the the
continuing ed date is a month from
tomorrow is that correct so we'll be
working through that program and and
send that to you for your review and in
case you want to provide input on that
the OLS trifold as we've mentioned we
should have that draft ready for your
review in a week or two when you guys
give that kind of a stamp we can send it
out to the rest of legislators so we can
start to put that into practice
eleanor-wise I'm going to schedule
another meeting at two weeks
from from today so you can think about
uh at that meeting anything you might
want to present to us or that might be
and then we've given you a list of some
committees that you can review for
potential repeal
and we'll as we get more we'll we'll
just share them with you right
so representative Dolan so you're
looking at September 25th yes at one yes
okay
as we think about uh uh scheduling
committee chairs coming to to talk with
us about the Committees and commissions
that are under their jurisdiction I
wonder if we can also invite uh ranking
members as well who may provide a
slightly different perspective on the
importance of certain issues
um I think it'll make sure that we
continue to operate in a really
bipartisan way I agree very good idea it
also generally the ones who serve on
them as well too
many leadership how do we call it that
committee leadership do we want uh
chairs Vice chairs and ranking members
or just chairs and ranking members you
think
I think either way I mean I'd be good
for them to let everyone know I know on
the Democratic side we've got you know
ranking members and Deputy ranking
members so I think you have I think I
think it's important for the chairs and
the ranking members to be there and then
if they want to let other members their
committee know that we're gonna have
this conversations obviously open to the
public
one of the Hallmarks of this committee
thus far is that we've had no uh
party interference or or uh or or
issues like I think we're all on the
same page just this is something that
needs to be done
regardless of the content this is more
of a process and procedure change that
okay well thank you guys very much
um just
we want for the items for the next
meeting and so we will have that for you
and okay
uh yes tri-fold
that's probably the biggest thing and
and we started looking at that and the
spreadsheet if we can see if we can get
it to help us do a sort on the
spreadsheet so that we could say tell me
how this all tears into the education
committee chair whatever
yeah I'm not sure if that that field
will be available yet but I had I had
promised um all chairs that I would send
them a list of their commissions and
committees so what I could do is I could
put you on the CC of each of those
emails if that's yeah that's cool okay
the the and I'll share it with with all
of you guys
but the export feel free I'm going to
send you a link feel free to play around
with the export just knowing that we're
working to clean up the data can you
help
um with the clerk's office you get the
notice out of our next meeting
yes your committee assistant is Jamie
and she automatically does that so she's
listening right now because you because
you booked that through house Community
Services hey Jamie hi Jamie she's
okay and hopefully yeah that's my plan
maybe we'll be deeper closer to the win
thank you all very much you're welcome
to stay and listening to the rest of the
discussion we're going to have but um
I think
I think we can let you guys go now thank
you
actually we're not closed on Columbus
State
yeah we'll still have a discussion about
it because I'm not
I'm not sure how everybody feels about
meeting on Columbus Day especially with
those those of us who have children that
will be home from school that need our
attention
I think we need to stay sensitive to
that
we certainly don't want people having to
go out hire child care for them
a week after that
doesn't matter
well a week before
I also want to flag the 25th I think is
Yom Kippur the question
or the
25th
in October 30th that'll be close to
Halloween
it's always holidays somewhere
so the 25th of October is a year 25th of
September
is good October 9th is Halloween uh
I have no problem with that
until midnight Columbus Day will be a
how about um
October 10th
it's a Tuesday
you guys have committee meetings on
Tuesday
I don't have my calendar
I forgot John has scheduled anything
I know he's scheduled one day
full bore
Okay so subcommittee
so do you have an objection to Yom
Kippur the 25th
or just uh you want to just alert it was
well over 20. I think more than anything
I want to make sure it wasn't a conflict
for anybody on the committee it's been a
long day
or anybody that we might be inviting I
would be yes I think if if you have a
religious holiday that if you feel
compelled to observe that I think we
need to honor that
and we just need to be careful that uh
if there is a widespread observance of
that holiday it doesn't put us into a
situation where we don't have a quorum
so
um I mean if we lose one or two members
to a religious holiday as long as we
still have a quorum that I'm okay with
that but I don't wanna
schedule something and then not then
lose the Quorum because of that so if
you all could what's that
uh
the 25th of this of this month is Yom
Kippur
so if if I would ask you to look at that
and if that's a
an objectionable day for you and and
or that's a religious observe and state
for you that will cause you to be absent
uh let me know and then I'll I can
evaluate whether or not would affect our
Quorum and 10 9 I think is already off
the table because if it's it's a going
to be a school holiday so I'm looking at
10 10. so let me know if
uh look check the calendar the house
calendar and see if it conflicts with
any of your regular committee meetings
yes
um so I Yom Kippur is one of the Jewish
High holy days and I I'm
we don't know yet who else we're going
to want to come to the committee on that
day so it's also going to limit I mean
we don't have a way of knowing whether
we'd be inviting somebody who celebrates
that
um and then I also checked with um my
family has off school that day so I'm
not sure that I'll be available so what
do you
yeah
I have the trifold and I think it'll
instead of that yeah
all right no that sounds great to me
let's let's do that let's plan our next
meeting
Jamie did you get that
so so that way we can avoid the high
holy day Yom Kippur on the 25th and also
hopefully we can avoid the
the Columbus Day holiday on the 9th of
October
and so we're going to meet October 2nd
and then two weeks after that'll be the
16th what's that
yeah let's we'll be targeting this the
16th
for the next meeting Beyond October 16th
October no October 2nd and then 16th
right that's that's what I said yeah
yeah
okay I know I won't be able to be there
on the 16th but that's
I'm the only one carry on
all right
thank you all right a couple other
things I want to talk about I mentioned
the rules committee uh that will be
available to us to uh to do some
legislative action towards the end of
the year
um
and that uh Matt's got some good input
that uh when we start interviewing
cheers to call in the ranking members as
well so that we we continue to have a
unified approach here and not just a
um
one thing that I did want to comment on
whether when uh John and I met with the
speaker and his staff
to give an update as to how our
committee was doing but we did that in
June and
the speaker
was pleased I can say this I
characterized his mood that he was
pleased that we had made some progress
that we've got some templates that are
that are coming especially uh in order
to focus we because we have focus focus
more on the process
thus far in this committee as opposed to
actually repealing
committees or or commissions
and that's
to be next I guess
uh I I didn't get a sense he didn't say
he was disappointed the fact that we
didn't
have a whole list of uh committees ready
but I get the sense
my characteristic
characterization that he was a little
disappointed that we didn't have that
but he understands what we're up against
because he's been through this before
and uh it was very difficult before
especially with the with the whole
interference of of covid and how covet
interrupted uh
more than we then we can we can really
talk about I mean with all the uh the
changes in the
how we meet and
what's a quorum and
electronically meetings and so forth so
that that's behind us yet we're still
dealing with the impact of that so he
understood all that I think he was
pleased that we had some plans going
forward and he's also pleased with with
uh
staff members that said that they felt
good about the progress
and again focused on the we're focusing
on the process
it was it was uh it was a take away from
me from that meeting with him
that he his hope is that by the end of
the year
we have at least two or three dozen
named committees
that will will be putting into the
category of repeal
so if we could set that as our informal
Target as we go forward
that would I think fulfill his
um
desires and I think
you can all speak for yourselves but I
think that that is going to be a a real
push for us and that would I think we
could declare at least first year
Victory uh
if we if we did that and then we can
build upon that
for 2024.
um
we got a good list
that the staff brought us that gets us
up to probably a dozen or so
and I can tell you
if you look at the third line down
the commission on demographic Trends I I
do know that that uh
that I there was an already
a some legislation brought forward to
Edna to
to add another committee on Democratic
demographic Trends in spite of the fact
that this one already exists
and
just by the and it was rejected because
by the chairperson because
we we get so much good data out of unh
right now they do this and they do it
for us for free
uh and we don't and we can choose to
accept or reject it when it comes but it
doesn't require a commit a committee or
a commission to do anything just to get
the data right into the committee and
then the committee can decide what to do
with it so uh that's a
again a minor Victory but
we'll take it if that's all we can get
it right now yes
um do we want to does somebody on this
committee want to file legislation with
respect to that list right there this
week and there's a couple of reasons for
that one is that we
potentially have legislation that so a
retained bill
has to be acted upon right fair you know
within I think by January 3rd right
it has to be acted on within a given
time frame
if we file legislation with that
that pretty much opens the door that
that could be amended
anytime between now and crossover
it might just make things a little bit
easier I don't know if we have to go
back to the rules committee either I
think with the two-thirds vote I think
we could introduce legislation anytime
if I'm not mistaken but it's just
another Avenue a suggestion that we
might want to put it now or somebody
might want to put it in LSR this week
with those committees on it
um
in order to
have something in place that could be
amended either either passed as is or or
amended
I think it makes a lot of sense from
just a timeline perspective rather than
needing a majority of the rules
committee or two-thirds of the house you
know to introduce a new bill
um to take what we've got here now and
then bring an amendment
um when it's heard in front of ledge
admin or who knows maybe gets assigned
to our committee
and I've been kind of hoping we'd do
something like that so that people could
see we're moving forward trying to do
something to correct the problems we
have coming from you Andy who do you
think might come up here
all right come on up there so we can
everybody I think it would be good as a
placeholder
thank you what represents petusic just
said makes uh Cole fault makes a lot of
sense but you do have to see that column
that where it has the explanation so I
don't know if you put all nine bills on
there automatically because I think
maybe like representative hunt I believe
is putting in repeal language for
something and I believe representative
Harrington is putting in repeal language
so maybe uh you you do put in a bill
because that's what we used to do we
used to have one bill that will list all
the repeals and maybe that's what you do
as a placeholder and start off with
would that be a bill that would be put
in through the wedgie admin or is that a
standalone bill that I I think what
representative Koval just said to just
put in an LSR
um right now that that you would start
the list but you'd have to look at the
list that you have and decide which ones
would be in there because there are some
that explain why they're still in
existence and some well a strategy could
be to put them all on the list and then
we can always edit edit the uh the LSR
we could line a few out if they're not
ready or if we made a mistake or
whatever
and change it that in that way what do
you what do you think
I I agree or you know the whatever
committee it's assigned to can can
essentially work with it from there with
a recommendation an informal
recommendation from this committee well
captures all not nine of these right
I believe so it captures all nine of
these would it would
suspect the speaker would assign that
out to because it would have come to us
come to assigned to our committee I
think it would be it speaker is going to
start assigning bills to the child care
committee and the housing committee
which are also special committee so I
imagine we can make a strong case for it
to be assigned here
and I I would make the recommendation
there's what's still unclear to me is
what's the process we're using to make
sure that the right commissions end up
on this list because uh
I don't know the political ramifications
putting all nine of these on here and
finally it is an LSR it could be that we
just file it with one for now but we
know we're absolutely committed to
repealing
um but I think that's something we need
to flesh out as a committee is figure
out like yes we're inviting chairs and
ranking members to join us to offer
feedback about bills that are in there
uh under their jurisdiction but what's
the process we're going to go through
what's the standard what are the you
know similar to the tri-fold what are
the things that need to be part of a
commission in order to create one what
are the things that we're looking for
what's the criteria we're using to
decide what end up on this list because
it's no small thing I all for you know
removing some committees and commissions
that are some commissions that we
deem are you know inactive that's one
thing right but if it's uh you know if
it's duplicative how do we determine
whether or not it's duplicative I just
think we need to have some conversations
to figure out what that is but agreed um
my my intention was simply to sort of
get the ball rolling so that we have a
placeholder so that's
in a
practically speaking
one of the ways to do this is to pick
one that we're sure of yeah and then add
to it
on some discussion we could add up to
nine so
eight more or the reverse put all nine
on there and start deleting ones that
we're not sure
if you have any
representative yeah I I'm agreeing with
what everyone's saying I'm thinking once
a bill is drafted and I'll it'll come
back so that we can have a look at it
before it's finally signed off we've got
it what's our window of opportunity
there how many days is there a limit
I've forgotten I I don't know what
you're I don't know what I mean I know a
deadline is Friday but then after that
once it's drafted out yeah that's not
what I'm thinking today 10 days and then
they all have to be this is drafted
what's drafted I don't think we're going
to have time to review it at our
our next meeting
on October the 2nd yeah I I think that
too much time on the calendar will tick
off and then it will die I think we've
got 10 days to
um right so we'll have we'll have 10
days once OLS sends it back to the prime
sponsor
10 days for the prime sponsor and also
all co-sponsors to sign off
um and then
um I think November 2nd is the final
date for all sign-offs whether or not
they get you have the 10 days or not
um November 2nd I think is the is the
final date
the Senate has a different schedule
um I don't think we want to do this as a
Senate bill but I mean that's just
another comment here
um so they have a wider window of
opportunity so yeah I mean I I guess my
my thought based on what you said
um is that we probably want to just take
the the most obvious one that we want to
repeal one
uh
uh one commission and uh draft a bill
somebody needs to step forward as the
prime sponsor of that
um
that person presumably cannot fully
participate in debate on the bill once
it comes if it comes to this committee
so we might want to have someone outside
of this committee do that
um it just seems to me that like with
with a we could relatively easily put a
placeholder in effect now that would
yeah
open yourself check with John Hunt he
said he was going to put in a bill to
kill one that'll be the bill
okay
that'll be the place
the fourth line down
the commission on the status of Health
coverage markets for individuals and
small employers
and that one sunsets at the end of 2024
yeah anyway so it
probably the easiest and least
controversial here exactly would be my
guess
amend the crap out of it later you know
this one Well we'd have to amend it
prior to our next meeting because the
deadline no not if it's assigned to us
as a committee if it's assigned to us as
a committee or any other committee we
can propose amendments through the
committee process and then basically up
until Crossover with those amendments
those amendments add additional
commissions to be deleted
and and I would assume that
I mean worst case
some you know the speaker says it's
non-germaine and we have to hold it a
non-germaine Amendment hearing
but I I I yeah I doubt we're going to
get a crowd for that so
again just just suggesting that if we
want to do that this week as the window
of opportunity to do it
and if if we think that representative
Hunt is going to be filing a bill we
need to make sure so that
we don't miss the Wednesday to write the
LSR
yeah
I'll actually be seeing him tomorrow my
morning at a meeting yeah
and can ask him what his intense is and
see that the committee is considering
filing legislation to repeal
would that be agreeable well all right
Next Step you know after that meeting is
to identify an author of The LSR yes I
think it's representative hunt I think
it sounds like representative pun's
already going to file the LSR he's
already planning to file that one it's
just confirming that he's going to get
it in this week and I think that's what
representative law is going to do
okay
sounds like a plan to me
anybody I think it would it would be
helpful if some of us maybe signed up to
be co-sponsors
or representative hunt
or does that mean we can't discuss it
as co-sponsors we may not be
able to participate fully in the
discussion
If he if he sponsors it
it's an insurance bill it's going to
okay
and I'm on the subcommittee
and you're good with that representative
hunt uh
understanding
representative wall you're going to
speak to him specifically about this
issue and what our strategy is
that would work I'm happy to talk to
them about that
um he's chairing the Committees I'll be
I talk to him all the time anyway
and it could be that we asked him to add
another
one or two commissions that we feel like
you know are also pretty
non-controversial because then if
there's a variety of subject matters I
think it will increase the likelihood of
it being assigned to this committee and
okay and uh what I can do is I can get a
message to the speaker because as he
assigns these these uh to the Committees
maybe I can convince them just to sign
and this will be kind of a test a test
bed for us with this first uh effort
right because I know he's looking for us
to stop making some progress and he can
help us by assigning it to us
yeah he'll be happy to see there's a
bill right
okay good I think that's uh
good progress
anybody else have any final comments
before we we close our session it
covered everything I was planning on
yeah we got some good input I like the
fact that they're inviting ranking
members I think that's good input for to
could we look to do that to invite the
committee chair star are we a few
meetings out from that or are we
thinking I think I'll take that on as a
project I was just curious
who the who the chairs are that are
candidates for this yeah and I'll I'll
uh I'll I'll work with Anne and we'll
see about uh inviting them putting them
on the agenda if you will of our
our upcoming meetings so that we we can
kick off a discussion let's say a one
o'clock discussion and then maybe at 1
15 or 1 30 we start you know chairman X
and ranking member y are going to talk
to us oh we're going to talk to them
about about this and maybe another half
hour we could have another one come in
maybe I'm thinking two or three for a
meeting does that sound right to you
it is the idea that we would talk to
them sort of about what we're trying to
do here initially and then potentially
invite them back with you know to come
back with a list as you suggested with
the potential technique
or I could prep them ahead of time
okay and then probably in that case we
give them a little more time before
before the date we give them to come in
right obviously to prepare but okay I
was just curious I guess either way that
okay
any other comments or feedback
good suggestions thank you and thank you
Ann for all the hard work I know behind
the scenes
and uh
and
the young lady that's monitoring our uh
Jamie Jamie our staff thank you
appreciate it and and so and I'll get
back to you Jamie about
we need to add some
detailed
comments on on
the agenda the next agenda if if we can
nail down some
some guest speakers if you will and do
you have any thoughts about whether you
or Deborah need to need to speak at our
next meeting
we
to explain triple okay
all right let's let's I think I think
it's healthier for us to plan on it if
we have to cancel it off the agenda
we'll cancel it but let's plan because
we have three weeks
so
yeah
all right thank you everybody and uh
please keep in mind the solemnness of of
today with the anniversary of 9 11 and
uh and have a good rest of the day thank
you
foreign